you are now live with layer eight culture
tech thursday
Thank you.
you are now live with layer eight culture
tech thursday
Let me add you to the stage, Cam.
Okay.
How's it going, Cam?
It's going super well, man.
I like that intro.
Appreciate it.
Let me get you in the group talk
here.
Oh, I kicked you off the stage.
There we go.
All right.
Am I glitching like crazy?
yeah you are oh man what is going
on here is that the new cam are
you on your laptop cam this is the
new cam that i got but it's want
to go maybe just to laptop yeah it's
gonna be a pain but you can do
that oh let me drop out i'll be
right back actually let me i'm gonna
restart uh you can hold it down
Play that intro whenever you come back in,
though.
All right, bro.
I'll be right back.
Let me restart this thing, man.
I don't know what's going on.
Hopefully that fixes it.
I'm over here eating lamb chops and sweet
potatoes, you know.
Tech guys got to eat, too, you know.
Yes, sir.
We are in the building.
We're like twenty four hours and sixteen
minutes of streaming.
Donville is getting his camera together.
Guys just see what he's been working on,
man.
You got some, some awesome stuff.
Doing digital media assets,
building web apps.
Thank you.
this time to get a beverage wash my
hands shout out to miss barker for hooking
up that lamb
OK, we're back.
Where you at?
in the building.
And back in just a second.
So tonight is we'll talk about me that
twenty four hour live stream.
I was there was epic.
And I definitely want to get into how
we use the Higgs field.
Yeah, I chat GPT Claude Fable five.
That's the new one that just came out.
And it will definitely touch on those
things tonight.
So let's give it a little second.
How's it going to work out?
It's working good now.
I don't know what it was,
but I guess I had to do a
reboot because I thought it was the cable
or something.
But as soon as I did the reboot,
everything's looking real nice now.
Yeah, nice and crispy.
Got the fish in the back.
Yep.
This is the lab right here, man.
That's where the magic happens, you know?
I love it.
It's a culture.
That's what we do.
Let's do it.
Yeah, man.
So, man, Cam, a stream, man.
I know.
I was just saying right now we're like
twenty four hours and nineteen minutes.
Yeah, man.
So what do you what do you think
about it, man?
How was it?
Tell me, like your thoughts.
What'd you learn?
It was,
it was just such a mind opener, man.
It's, and it's funny because,
and we kind of talked about this that
night,
but leading up to the hackathon is like,
you kept encouraging me to just think
bigger and to think more.
And so when we were in there for
twenty four hours,
then it was really starting to hit me
like,
Oh, okay.
Like literally anything you can think of
can be built, you know?
So yeah,
my whole mindset is different after that.
How about you?
Man, I gotta say, like, I keep,
I keep thinking about it and like every
single time it's like something new pops
up, like a new idea, a new thought,
a new concept.
Just,
I think locking in for twenty four hours
was so important because
not only were able to learn,
but to be able to gather that much
data.
And then as you reflect on it,
like you start coming up with even more
ideas, man, more concepts.
Like, you know, I'm a systems person.
So I think about how systems work,
about how to operationalize things.
And like,
just so much is coming out of that,
especially when it comes to AI,
when it comes to business,
when it comes to how people learn,
you know, like I sent you that link.
about putting in just the twenty hours
like to learn something new you gotta put
twenty hours in and some people especially
in this era where you're on social media
everything's like a short everything's
like a thirty second clip a one minute
clip you know at most you go through
that like you go through twenty clips on
the same subject you feel like oh I'm
an expert like man you just spent twenty
minutes on that yeah what are you doing
you know like so having that deep
That's that dedicated time to learn,
to go deep, like to install,
but then use and then like go back
and fix things and work things out.
Like it's so, so valuable, man.
It's so valuable.
Yeah, no, I agree.
And not only what it really did for
me, you know,
I'm more like you're super big systems
tech.
I'm like mindset and framework.
And what it did is it lets you
know how much you can really get done
if you just really applied yourself.
Like if you were working on something
super important and you just did,
you know,
two twelve hour days and just really like
push through it it's like you can get
so much done you know what i'm saying
and so yeah that's what that's when four
hours did it's like we got so much
done oh yeah man and i think at
one point that i always tell everyone when
i'm talking about the funniest part
It was like two o'clock in the morning.
You were like, Hey, I got this, uh,
I got this customer.
Like I'm,
I'm falling asleep on the other side.
Like I'm so tired.
I'm about to take a nap.
You're like grinding away on your own,
bro.
That's the amazing part.
You're on your own.
Just like building this app and fixing it
up.
And I'm like, dude, I'm falling asleep.
You got something to send me.
You're like, Hey, I got this website.
You want to build it?
I'm like, yeah, let's go.
You know?
It goes into the whole point of how
using AI in the right way really energizes
you and gets you to that next level
where it motivates you.
Like, man,
I just got this thing out in under
an hour.
Let me jump on another project.
Let me fix another problem that I have.
How can I fix that with AI?
It's just interesting that in itself how
fast we're able to build a full-fledged
website get you on board like to be
able to teach you and i know like
the terminal the you know command line
interface a lot of people they're like hey
it's too much i can't do this down
but like what are you talking about but
for you to jump in bro and just
head first and like understand it like all
right i mean safe hands with donaldville
like i got this that's just awesome to
see that man
yeah and that's another thing man like
that same video you sent you know as
far as like the twenty hours this and
that they're talking about the biggest
hurdle is just people who just never get
started you know and it seems so
overwhelming it seemed like it's so
complicated but if you just sit down and
just do it you'd be surprised how like
oh it's not that bad and so what
you really need and again i really think
that's what layer eight does right
like it it makes it possible for you
to get started without the pressure you
know doing it by yourself and being
isolated that's when you freeze up and
don't do anything but when you have
someone walking you through it and just
guiding you like step by step then it's
like oh and then once you get in
it you get in a little pocket
Then I remember that like I got a
little pocket.
I wanted to kind of do something
innovative.
You had to bring me back like, hey,
I'm one thing at a time.
What you doing?
Hold up.
OK, OK, OK.
I want to get a little saucy,
you know what I'm saying?
But that's OK.
Like, I think that's part of it.
Right.
I think that's OK if you want to,
you know, explore a little bit.
And because that's that's how you do
things, man.
You break it, you fix it,
do it again.
And so now it was fun, though, man.
It was a great sprint, a great experience.
And once again, man, it's super thankful.
Definitely.
Thank you for opening the office.
Big shots to Flopflow,
one of our sponsors here at Layer Eight
Culture.
And like you said,
you said it just right, Cam.
That's exactly what we're about.
Like building, encoding,
creating is not something we need to do
in a silo.
There's no need to hoard ideas.
Like, come on, what are we doing?
Like everything's, it's data.
It's all open.
Like, why are we trying to hoard ideas?
thoughts and ideas and processes like
let's share the world hence the word right
that's really who you're doing it for yeah
exactly so i'm gonna bring up this to
sage i think i know what's going on
cam i don't know what it's like every
time i touch this window it passes out
but anyways just wanted to bring this up
um tonight we're gonna touch on a pretty
cool ai
platform that I've been messing with
called Higgs field.
And man, like if you,
have you been on the site before?
Have you heard about Higgs field?
I have not.
Oh man.
It's insane.
You're going to love this game.
I think for like,
and this is not an advertisement,
but you can get a plan.
I think I have like the,
it's a test things out.
And the cool thing is you get access
to all these models.
Like, here you go.
Here's all the models.
C-Dance, they're really big on video.
You'll see the OpenAI models there.
You'll see the Google VO.
That's another video model.
Gronk is like all of them are there
at your disposal.
But then, of course,
they charge you different credits.
So I've been interested in just the image
models and how they all function and
operate.
So that was like my initial thought on
how to use it.
And just to be transparent, to me,
at least,
the image models aren't as good as what's
offered in ChatGPT.
So I'll show you.
I'll be transparent, just show you.
Actually, no, it's not there.
It's the assets.
It's sort of the assets.
So you see all this stuff I've been
creating for layer eight.
And the images
What was that?
Is this where you did that intro?
Yeah, yeah.
I did some video after.
But, like,
I initially started some images.
And these early images are very basic.
But, like, I was using the MCP.
And I don't know if you remember.
You can set up an MCP,
Model Context Protocol.
And you can put it.
So the MCP lives in the CLI.
environment,
so like your Cloud Code or your GitHub
COBOL CLI.
And then you could use that to interact
with the image model and then basically
have it automate to tell the image model
what to do and what to create.
So that's what I did with this.
These are all images,
like a batch of images that I was
like, hey,
this is the type of image I want.
I let the GitHub COBOL CLI just have
at it.
connecting automatically to my account and
just create some images and then i looked
i was like it's not really what i
wanted so then i was like you know
what let me just see how it does
as far as the layer eight imagery that
i've been using doing with a chat gpt
and like it came out it just it
just wasn't like the quality that i wanted
i don't know if it was the prompts
but
wasn't feeling it bro so definitely not
bad yeah it's not it's not bad but
i don't know you got some high standards
but you know man i do i mean
this was pretty cool but yeah but then
and then here's the thing like you can
use different models so i know everybody's
been like oh nana banana
So I kind of just stuck with one
model.
So I didn't even mess with the other
models.
So that might have been my mistake to
maybe explore a little bit more with the
models.
But what I did was I went back
to my favorite GPT.
And my GPT images are like, they're fire.
It's so consistent.
GPT don't miss.
What'd they say?
They don't miss.
There we go.
So I could fast scroll through this.
Hopefully I'll get some imagery.
What is it?
Actually, you know what?
Let me just break this thing out.
There we go.
Let's go.
So boom.
There's your layer eight imagery, right?
All GPT.
GPT is sometimes...
This is some cool stuff I did.
I got this thing called Stream Deck.
I create some custom icons.
I'll get into that in a different episode.
Here's my son.
We're working on this video game.
He's got some storyboard stuff.
It's pretty cool, man.
He's got a whole story that he's building
out.
We're going to have to take some time
and do an episode on that.
As you can see, it's very consistent.
And the quality, I just love the quality,
man.
Yeah.
It's detailed.
It's got a certain vibe to it.
It's very vivid.
And it's hard to replicate that.
Even you see how the room is dim,
it's blurred, the person's in focus.
Man, this stuff matters, you know?
Right.
Like I was saying,
you definitely got your theme dialed in.
Yep.
sure that's the website these are the
graphs even to like the uh infographics
that i've created they're all on theme so
i say all that to say that i've
got this pretty cool process and that's i
want this to be the highlight of the
night so what i did was i went
back to gpt started talking to chat of
course i'm on five point five and the
cool and this quick plug
When you go to five point five and
you're on a paid account,
I don't know how it is on a
free account,
but right here you go to five point
five.
But then you have your your.
I forgot the word for it,
but you're thinking like.
And I forgot the word,
but basically you can hit a model,
you go to a different model and then
you could.
Like, I think it's called the reasoning.
The reasoning could be a medium, high,
instant.
And what this does is it really goes
through a thought process.
When I say it's the AI,
it goes through a thought process of like,
is this really what the user wants?
Like, let me build,
let me reflect and validate what I've just
built.
then we go back to the original question
like hey is this really what the user
wanted and the answer is no it actually
say no like now let me fix this
let me go back so it does take
a little bit longer but the result that
you get is a more is more crisp
for me i'm just always on high because
i i got time to spend i'm not
like i'm not super like i need this
now now now it's always go high you
notice a big time difference
yeah at times so i think what happens
is there's certain times like around
evening time like i would say four four
and five o'clock for some reason are times
where it takes much longer and like those
people getting off work or something i
don't know yeah it's like the whole
internet days back in the day you know
slow down or yeah i feel like everybody's
hitting it a certain time and it does
kind of bog down slow down but um
for the most part i can go high
i could
I don't mind it spending a couple seconds
going over the thought process and it's
like, hey, boom.
And the cool thing is, like,
if you tap your notifications turned on,
it'll notify you when it's done with
something.
You can run multiple chats at the same
time.
All right.
It's fun stuff.
But anyways,
so I always run minds at high.
I said all that to say this.
And then, so I'm going back to chat.
I'm like, hey, chat.
Yeah,
I'm trying to do this thing with Higgs
field.
And I want to do, like, a video,
like,
Help me out with a prompt.
Because I think ChatGPT is really good at
providing clear prompts.
So I asked, like, hey,
help me out with a prompt.
And if I could find it here,
because this is like,
I need to get more organized on my
chat instances.
That's another sidebar I got to get into.
But here we go.
This is, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this is about around this.
This is around where I started.
I was like, hey.
Oh, here we go.
Boom, boom, boom.
This is where it told me.
It actually told me what to do.
All right, here we go.
Nope, that's not it.
Okay, let's see.
Gosh, there's so much going on.
So anyways, I can't find the exact prompt,
but the idea is ChadGBT told me like
the best,
the recommended way that Hickville
actually tells you,
they're supposed to tell you somewhere in
their documentation,
that the best way to do a video
clip is to take some still shots and
piece them together with a prompt
And then you'll have, like, these clips.
So, like, see how it says, like,
frame one to frame two?
That's, like, one image, two image.
That's an animation.
This next set is another animation.
This one's another.
So, like, literally, you end up with one,
two, three, four,
five different video clips, right?
So then I go back and I'm like,
hey, chat.
you help,
I want you to help me out with
the, like, explain this, like, yeah,
you need six frames, I'm like, okay, chat,
you're gonna give me the six frames, like,
just, like,
give me a reference image of the person's
face, which is me,
and then give me a, um,
image of the environment,
I just took this, this imagery, right,
took that,
kind of told it roughly what I wanted
to do,
I wanted to go from a corporate office
to, like, a more, you know,
layer eight lab,
and to
And I,
and the cool thing that we talked about
this this morning, bro, like, Hey,
please create all six frames using these
images of reference.
Like I told it, you better create six.
Cause so like chat GPT is weird.
Like if you let it decide,
it might give you two and you'd be
like, Hey, I need more images.
Or it might give you three.
It may,
it just gives you like whatever it feels
like.
Right.
I told it specifically six frames cause I
needed the six.
So this is how it starts with frame
one.
Frame two, he's on his laptop typing.
Frame three,
he shuts the laptop for a day.
And here's the kicker, bro.
If you look at this right here,
you see this?
Frame one, it's daytime.
Check this out.
The detail.
That's what I'm talking about.
ChatGPT is so good at just the details
and the imagery if you get it right.
So, of course,
the consistency is still there.
Um, and then boom,
he transforms into the hoodie.
Like, this is so like,
this is what directors do in the movie,
in the movie studios.
Like they have a storyboard in real life.
Yeah.
Frame by frame.
And then boom,
he's in the lab and then, Hey,
it's slavery culture.
Right.
So awesome.
I have all that.
And I'm like, Hey, thanks chat.
I'm going to use VO three point one
and.
It gave me the guidance for each
transition and all that.
And then I'm like, hey,
I need these prompts.
So then chat gives me the prompts, right?
Awesome.
But this is how we learn.
So here's the thing.
I was like, all right, chat,
GPT recommended VO three point one to use,
right?
But, like,
the first two video clips came out pretty
good, right?
They were good.
When I got to video clip three,
I started getting, like,
this not suitable for work tag.
Like, it wouldn't generate the image.
It was like, hey, we can't do this.
I'm like, yo, what are you talking about?
It's a prompt.
Like, there's nothing crazy in there.
And so I went back to chat and
I'm like, chat, this is what it's saying.
Not super for work.
Chat's like, okay, let me do this.
Maybe it's, I think chat,
even chat was thinking like, oh, maybe,
maybe cause you said it was a black
person.
Like, it's like,
you're talking to somebody, right?
So chat's like,
maybe it's cause you said it was a
black person.
Let me give you a slimmed down version
of this.
So then, um, it gave me another version.
I uploaded it in and just keeps rejecting
it.
And the cool thing about Higgs field is
that, um, when it rejected,
it didn't like take my credits away.
Cause every time you use a model,
you get like these credits that
for a certain timeframe.
If it's four K, if it's ten ADP,
it costs.
So it would credit my stuff back.
So I just kept kicking back.
And I was like, you know,
I'm real careful with my tokens, bro.
You know,
so like between all the platforms and all
the cooking you be doing is like, yeah,
I can see like somebody who don't pay
attention to add up.
Oh man.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't just give you a credit card and
just be like, Hey, no limit.
Like, nah, you won't get a hefty bill.
Yeah.
Like, but, um, yep.
So, so then I was like,
let me use this other model called cling
three point.
No, I think it's called, uh,
where is it?
on it.
Oh, you got to play the video now.
Cause you don't get so much anticipation
and this and that.
Exactly.
So we go to generate, here we go.
So boom.
So clean three point O's by use.
And all you do is you load in
the first frame, second frame.
I paste this prompt in from chat GPT.
I could set the duration.
So I can do like longer.
A drawer, you can see how the credits,
they run out based on time.
I could do four K that's going to
cost more,
but this is all like social media stuff.
I mean, he's perfectly fine, but like,
I'll get into it later,
but cause I have another idea.
So like literally generated it and it does
take a little bit longer.
Of course you're generating videos,
but it's kinda like you could run two
at a time.
And then kind of set it and forget
it and come back later and check it
out.
So, like,
here's the sneak peek of another video I
made.
Just that turnaround.
I know, right?
And here's, like,
so that was the six-second one.
Here's the ten-second one.
And this is just off of two clips?
Yeah, two pictures and a prompt.
That's it.
So, like.
Just messing with these different ones,
man.
Like, here's a cool sliding one.
So here's the kicker.
So I was like, okay, well,
how am I going to clip all these
together?
And chat's like, hey, use CapCut.
I don't want to jump in.
Yep.
Indeed.
So I use CapCut.
I have CapCut on my desktop.
Actually, I can't get there right now.
Hold on.
Hmm.
And it's a pretty,
like you've used CapCut on a mobile phone
before.
It's super easy.
Like you take the video clips,
you drag and drop.
Actually, you know what?
Let me, this is all about sharing.
I got to share.
Let me stop and then I'll open up
CapCut.
This is so easy, man.
Like that's the thing.
I want to show people like how easy,
because that's the thing.
Like I can do,
my dad always told me,
you sure love to do things the hard
way when I was a kid.
I try not to share the hard way.
I try to do it the hard way
and then show people the easy way to
do it so you're not going to make
my mistakes.
That's my rationale for doing it the hard
way.
But let me share this real quick.
My screen.
I'm going to share CapCut.
Here we go.
So, this is CapCut.
It's actually, yeah, it's free.
Of course, like, you could pay for the,
um, the pro version,
but I don't even pay for that, like,
because they have a lot of free stuff.
Which is awesome.
So, you go on.
Yeah,
I've never used the desktop version
before.
Yeah, it's a little bit, like, the mobile,
I've always used the mobile.
This was actually my first time using the
desktop version.
I have had it before downloaded,
but I never really
used it but it's super simple you create
a new project you go to import here
you can import your content so i have
like these video clips here you have two
video clips and an image and this is
actually the outro for the stream here and
literally all i did was drag it in
boom one clip actually you know what we
got tom today
We got time today.
I'm going to show y'all how to do
this.
I want people to understand this is so
easy.
So clip one, boom.
Drop it, right?
Clip two, boom.
Drop it.
Clip three is just so what clip three
is, the image, is like, hey,
I wanted the text to show up like
here, right?
So what I did was I showed up.
a screenshot lesson.
I took a screenshot of clip.
The last frame in the clip to do
it in chat GPT was like, hey,
add this text is typography for me.
It did it.
And then now I just drop this image.
And with the images, of course,
if you know video editing,
like you could stretch your image out as
a still frame as long as you want.
Right.
So you drop that in.
Next up your transitions.
okay video editor i know right come on
you know me cam so so like yes
they have the pro stuff where you have
to pay for it but there's also free
stuff that looks pretty cool so you can
click on it so you like hey this
is what it's going to look like uh
you want something simple you go through
and then of course like you can search
for it so you're like hey i just
want a quick fade
And of course,
like ChatGPT is going to help you with
all this stuff.
It's going to tell you like what to
use, right?
So I take my fade.
I drop it right here on the video,
right in the middle between the two clips.
That's going to say whatever.
It's okay.
And then you can stretch out your fade
to like three seconds.
You know, let's say that, boom,
two point three seconds.
And then I could come here.
If I want to use the same fade,
I can.
flash fade doesn't matter so I see so
you went from prompt images to three
individual video clips to one continuous
video in Capcom layers definition of
layers I know right layers man that's the
method so now play this look how seamless
that is bro
Are you playing something right now?
I only see the three individual clips.
I don't know what screen you're streaming
now.
That's crazy.
Thanks for letting me know because I've
been like, show you all this stuff.
Hold on.
Let me fix this here.
No.
No, that's it.
oh you know what it created a new
window that's what it was boom man all
right here we go cam i've been talking
this whole time so what i did was
i literally just dragged down let me make
sure it's on stage perfect ah there you
go there we go so back to media
so we get in the clap cut you
open a new project you see the media
that you dropped in so like clip one
clip two
Your image and all I did was just
take these and drag these down into here.
I'm going to replace this clip.
I'm just going to show you because I
think this part is so valuable.
I want to make sure people see how
easy this is.
Clip one.
Clip two.
Your image.
All right.
And then you just click on transitions up
here.
I already got the fade.
So boom,
I drop it right in the middle.
I need another fade.
I dropped that in the middle.
Of course I could change my duration of
the fade, but we're going to,
we're going to keep it so simple, bro.
So boom.
I literally just did that in seconds.
I play it.
You got your preview up here.
Nice, cool transition.
So in new to end that one clip
where you're going to start.
Yeah.
Cause I was butted up.
Oh yeah.
When they've made the video clip,
that's why it's so important to do the
frame by frame.
So frame clip one starts with one image,
two image, right?
Clip two starts with image number two.
So the same image, one, two, then two,
three, you get like a seamless thing.
Yep, exactly.
Oh, that's good.
And then the cool thing about, um,
cap cut as well you could add audio
so like they have all these cool like
pro audios that you could put in but
let's say you want like a drone effect
i don't know drone cinematic that's music
hold on sound effects i want a drone
i'm like why is it giving me music
tracks drone
So I could,
and this is all free stuff.
So this is like a dramatic drone effect.
I could drop in my sound layer here.
I can mess with the fade,
like the ins and outs, like a transition.
It gives it a smooth, like,
increases the volume, like fades in.
I could do it up here as well.
I could fade out, fade in, both sides.
I can move this around.
I can have multiple layers of sound.
So like,
Let's say I want multiple sounds.
They'll have like birds chirping in the
background, like keyboards clicking,
like all this stuff is like available to
you where you can search it and bring
it in.
And that was really it, man.
I didn't even like mess with doing
anything else.
It's really just the transitions,
the sounds.
As far as the text for this stuff,
I was like, yo, chat,
take care of that.
and it looks so clean you know so
actually it's my first time using that
transition definitely look at that boom
like man come on like we don't like
people we don't need to use this trash
we don't use don't don't get it out
the box take your time do a little
set that context and look at that you
got premium quality stuff so here's the
kicker cam
Cause that's just like social media.
Okay.
It's cool.
Higgs field.
They have an explore button and this blew
my mind.
I want to see your take on this,
but if you go actually hold on,
let me share my screen again.
Cause I don't like sharing my entire
window.
So I'm sharing like window by window.
Top flight security stuff on there.
You already know how to get down, bro.
So yeah.
So boom, we're back on Higgs field.
Let me share it.
Bring back on the stage.
Here we go.
All right.
So Higgs field,
if you go up to this explore button
and Higgs field,
I'm going to need a promo for this
one.
Cause this I'm putting people on.
So I'm actually with any hyper-realistic
video.
That's what I'm about to talk about, bro.
So you go to the explore page,
they can have like demos of like what
people are building and look at this
stuff, man.
And saying, I saw this one.
I was like, Oh, this is crazy.
Look at this.
Look at that, dude.
It's still going.
This is a pretty long clip.
You know what I'm saying?
Boom, you want it in this format?
We could do that.
It's the same clip, bro.
Different angle.
Isn't that crazy?
Wow.
Bro, you want this format?
That's what somebody made or giving you
this as an option to use?
This is what someone made.
And that's just all off a prompt.
Yep.
I look at this like it's crazy.
Like the imagery.
Actually, they do.
So they do have GPT in here.
That's the thing, bro.
I pay twenty dollars a month for GPT.
I'm not going to pay extra.
For GPT, I'm, I'm a during like that,
but maybe I do need to pay and
to see like the quality of GPT in
here,
like GPT image two versus chat GPT image.
That's something I do need to play around.
Definitely has a different aesthetic.
This is,
this is what blew my mind cam.
This is what got me.
And let me know what you think about
this.
What platform is this?
Higgs field Higgs field.
Yeah, I know Higgs field,
but is this like a different model,
like within Higgs field?
No, Hicksville is the platform.
And then you have access to all the
different models within Hicksville.
That's what I'm saying.
The model that has all this UGC content,
what is it called?
They're all different models.
So these are all video models.
Yo, Chad, hold on, hold on.
It'll tell you right here.
Chad, is this real?
Hold on.
So this model is called Marketing Studio.
Yo, LinkinBio, go try it right now.
Yo, chat, hold on, hold on.
What is this?
Chat, is this?
And then they had like,
this blew my mind.
I was like, dude, this ASMR stuff,
literally off of a prompt.
Man,
if you had a product and you just
uploaded a picture of that product and did
all that.
And you don't even gotta like... Oh,
so is that the prompt on the right?
No.
Yeah.
They give you the prompt.
They're like, yo, you want to make this?
Recreate it.
Wow.
Let's build something, bro.
Let's build it.
Let's say this thing spin around the
block.
Yeah, but you can go in here.
They don't tax you fifty,
but let's do it.
Why not?
Let me know if I got to up
my retainer.
I don't know if that thing is exhausted
or yet.
I don't want to overstep.
You know what I'm saying?
Let me know.
We're getting into those metal buildings.
I want to see how hyper-realistic can you
do like barnuminiums.
Of course, you can.
Let's do an ad for her.
So we're going to attract contractors who
build barnuminiums.
I don't know.
We don't have that time.
I want to play it on live.
But it's something I'm going to take it
back to the lab, Cam.
And you know I'm going to come back
with some fire.
but crazy it is crazy man and then
even here's another idea bro like let's
say you don't want to do unboxing right
let's say you you're like somebody that's
super creative you like to make stories
you like to write books and you want
to like have your own tv show like
bro you can literally have a whole ai
series tv show you put you have the
clips you know
two minutes,
one minute and a half at a time,
and it becomes like a whole AI series.
You know what I mean?
Man, I bet them faceless YouTube channels,
I bet they're doing it.
Sure, tons of channels are doing stuff,
man.
But yeah,
that blew my mind from the marketing
aspect.
And then, yeah, just the quality.
It's just insane.
They actually have,
I did see they have a
a movie on here.
It's in the explore section.
You got a video game.
Yeah.
It's a great games.
How about Claude Fable?
All right.
That's how we go in this man.
So Claude Fable is insane.
So they I wasn't expecting this to come
out.
Not this soon,
but Claude has had this model
That they've kept under wraps called
mythos.
Let me go back and do my share
of things.
I keep forgetting.
Hold on.
Add this back here.
Boom.
stage all right here we go so lord
has this thing called mythos it's a model
that's supposed to be super advanced they
um they had it under wraps and it
was so advanced so powerful that they were
like we can't release this to the public
like this is gonna be horrible for hackers
and
people with ill intent so they've kept it
um private within anthropic two days ago
they dropped fable and they say that fable
is the mythos class that means it's it's
advanced to the point where they're
willing to say hey this is mythos grade
ai model
um that we're willing to release out to
the public right yeah i heard that man
i've seen some stuff online man what's the
other person they're using they're like
yeah this is i forget the word not
agent agent aji yeah something like that
yeah when you say aji that's like the
next level
like more self-learning,
self-contained type of AI.
I've already seen some.
Oh, here's some benchmarks.
If you want to geek out,
you can look at the numbers.
This is what we've used for the past.
It's so crazy how just two weeks ago,
were talking about four point eight opus
when we did the live stream right like
opus was just released when uh opus four
point eight i should say it was just
released when we did the live stream and
you talk about agentic coding you know uh
what are these numbers it's fundamental um
Is it saying,
compares the capabilities of menthols to
others leading models?
Why is it has a percentage?
I'm not understanding the chart.
I'm not too sure what the percentage
means.
Maybe I'm saying, I don't know.
I'm gonna take a stab in the dark
and maybe,
Accuracy or I don't know.
But I'm just going to say from a
culture standpoint that eighties is a
better number than sixty nine.
But it doesn't I don't know.
It doesn't tell me much as interesting.
You know what?
This is what we do.
We don't understand things.
Throw that thing in chat.
Exactly.
So I'm going to take a screenshot of
this real quick.
That's another thing I love to do is,
um, snipping tool.
Just throw it in chat and be like,
what does this mean?
Break this down in layman's terms.
I'm going to have to go help bake
my pay.
I got another business I got to go.
Nice.
She's in there.
Tomorrow's her big sale day.
So I'm going to have to break up
a little bit to go.
Okay,
I'm going to have to text you my
order.
I want some.
I've been talking about it for the past
year.
I do want some fresh sourdough bread.
I need that order.
She's about to roll out a jalapeno
cheddar.
Ooh.
That sounds good.
That sounds real good.
Put that on some salmon.
Some capers.
You know, I'll get down.
You know how to go get that almond
today.
Oh, you did?
You got it?
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm reading.
Let's see.
This model.
Okay.
What does the percentage mean?
That's all I wanna know, Chad.
Scoring on different AI benchmark tests.
Out of a hundred tests,
a hundred test tasks, oh,
the percentage is the amount of tasks that
it was able to complete correctly.
Okay, that makes sense now.
It would be cool if they said like
out of a hundred, right?
Anyways, so, out of a hundred tests,
Opus actually hit sixty,
only hit sixty-nine, which is surprising,
because that's, like, ooh, that's not,
that's not, like, awesome, right?
It's, like,
a thirty-one percent of your stuff is
errors, which is,
I wouldn't say that's awesome,
but Opus is pretty awesome.
But, for agentic coding, eighty percent,
you know, um,
So here's where we talk about frontier
code.
So these are really hard tests.
When it comes to that frontier code,
these are agents that are running
autonomously, twenty-four seven.
This is not one prompt.
These agents are continually doing work.
That's a pretty interesting number.
What's another interesting number?
These are close enough.
I would say these are close enough.
Biology, eighty percent.
So, oh, there's a whoa, you see,
look at that.
So remember,
I remember I talked about like them being
afraid to release some of this stuff
because of hackers.
Look at that cyber security.
This.
Fable V.
Seventy-eight percent of the time it was
able to crack this stuff.
That's big compared to forty percent.
Right.
That's the Mythos preview.
So it even got better.
This is preview Mythos.
This is Fable.
This is not even the real Mythos, people.
This is like the watered-down Mythos.
You want to see what Palantir's got?
and then health.
But yeah, that's, I think that's the big,
the biggest jump out of all of them.
Um, that, and yeah,
that's definitely the biggest jump.
And then the next big jump is the
genetic coding.
Very interesting.
But, um, yeah, it's there.
He's improving so fast.
Insane.
Two weeks, two weeks.
And the cool,
so the cloud subscription that I paid for,
it did give me access to Fable five,
but man, honestly,
I was telling someone the other day, like,
Claude is just, it's too bougie for me,
man.
Claude is like the Harvard, Oxford.
I feel like I'm in,
I'm walking through like Ivy League
school.
I like to get out of the mud,
man.
I like chat.
Chat is like, chat's for the people.
I feel like when I'm talking to chat,
like chat just breaks it down for me.
Like, okay, I don't need to,
you don't need a research paper, Don.
All you need is just, you know,
give me the meat.
that's funny uh we were building a um
like we we finally got the as manager
interface with Claude and we are building
like I think we're calling it campaign
campaign Hawk you know what I'm saying so
it watch all our campaigns
If it drops below a certain stat,
like a certain cost per lead or whatever,
we get notified.
We can filter, run reports and all that.
So we're doing all this in cloud and
cloud code, honestly.
And CJ's like, man,
like basically I ain't never going back to
chat.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm good, baby.
Thank you.
I ate all those cherries and grapes.
I'll be in there in a little bit.
Um, so yeah,
so that's funny you say that,
cuz now I don't know, man,
we started working on cloud and we like,
man, I kinda like this, you know?
So I, I, I,
I stay in there in cloud chat.
I like cloud chat, you know?
Mm-hmm actually, you know, I,
to be honest,
I think I'm not using it properly.
I've been,
I've been in cloud code this whole time.
It's it's called that AI it's called chat,
right?
Yeah.
So there's chat.
Co-work and code.
Yeah.
Just use the desktop version.
I mean, I'm in there, I'm,
I'm doing stuff in it.
I go back and forth cause it's a
whole table thing.
Still not sold yet.
I'm still like my go-to still chat.
And then I do need to sort out
the same way we clean up our,
you know, the office and stuff.
I do need to clear up my chat
GPT.
They do have project folders that I've
been using on certain things to keep it
boxed in.
That does actually help.
It's been good, man.
It's been good.
Oh, my bad.
No, I was saying,
I think the next thing is, like,
really getting into, like, skills,
learning skills, and then building, like,
actual...
agents who are going to just get the
whipping you know what i'm saying like you
can set them up in a computer and
they're just they're just moving so
there's so many like little uh
productivity,
like utility type automations you can do,
you know, like morning roundup,
check your emails,
check all the correspondence,
who you got to respond to,
who you got to like, just all that,
just like start getting all the,
whatever your everyday workflow is.
And that's the mindset, right?
You got to,
you got to no longer look at it
as like
just people it's what are the tasks within
each position in your organization and how
can you just streamline that workflow by
leveraging ai and yeah it's gonna it's
gonna change the game man
We'll get into all that, man.
Yeah, that's a session in itself,
you know.
Yeah, man.
Next Thursday.
Thanks for joining me.
I know we're going to figure out this
whole video thing,
but it was great to have you, bro.
Have that perspective.
Have that knowledge.
Have that reflection on the Twenty-Four
Hours stream.
Just have to be able to share a
lot of this knowledge with you, man.
So much going on.
So see you next time, bro.
All right, man.
Appreciate it.
God bless.
All right.
Later.